what do you think it'll take for you to
get over insecurity moving forward
i'm not trying you're not trying i'm not
trying to
i thought you said if you could get rid
of it you'd be able to do bigger the
unbelievable but but it's not it's not
it's not a target i have letting go of
insecurity no i think it's just a human
condition i think it's part of the game
i think it's part of being a human being
any more than i want to get rid of my
arms you know or my legs or
my arms and my legs my body my body is a
limitation yeah you know so um how do
you manage it better then like for
people that are saying i you know i want
a 10x but i always have insecurity and
fear that i'm going to fail and people
are going to show up and yeah the deal
is going i'm going to go broke
how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear yeah it's not stop
it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know
it's calling me says hey come play over
here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it lean
into come play with me okay so i either
have fear because it's really dangerous
and stupid
or like physically dangerous yeah like
let me get to the edge of this thing i'm
gonna get on the other side of that
thing i'm probably gonna be scared yeah
now
why am i gonna be scared though
like because i don't know what it feels
like to fall
you know this many floors and hit yeah
maybe it does maybe there's no big deal
about maybe dying is not even a big deal
right but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so
you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because you
have an experience i don't have the
experience man this this is the problem
and you're not going to have the
experience if you don't move through the
fear
and
a lot of people do it once and then they
don't do it again you got like
it's not going away yeah it's just gonna
you're gonna get used to
you're gonna get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't man
but you just wear into them yeah
if you're afraid that means you're on
the right track
if you are afraid to do the thing that's
on your list your dream list where you
want to go what you want to accomplish
if you're afraid of that thing if
looking at it makes your heart go boom
boom boom boom boom
it means you're on the right track
you do not want to live a life with no
fear
people ask me all the time how do i
how do i be fearless how do i conquer my
goals without fear you don't if you are
fearless if you have no fear in your
life
it means that you hate your life
it means that you are just photocopying
the same day on repeat over and over and
over again
you're only fearless if you know exactly
how it's going to play out right if you
knew exactly what's gonna happen
you will not be afraid
if you had to go
brush your teeth
you could do it you won't be afraid to
do it because you've done it a million
times before but it's also boring
imagine if you had your whole life
not being afraid
how bored you would be
and we we as humans we have this desire
for stability you don't want to be just
constantly in the unknown and constant
the fear and stressed out all the time
we want we want to have stability but
not too much stability because we also
want the variety we also want the spice
of life we also want to push we also
know we're capable of more you're
capable of more you've got giant
potential in you you got michael jordan
level genius is something new
it's not going to be realized by not
doing anything that you're afraid of
you have to jump into those things now
think about what you're afraid of most
of the things that we're afraid of are
not actually
physically harming to us think about
what's what are you most afraid of what
do you really want to do that you're
afraid of most of the time it's not
something that's actually going to cause
you physical harm right i would be
afraid to go
rob this store or steal this car right i
mean i'm afraid to do that but i don't
want to do that
it's it's it's not in my ambition to do
that
uh especially since it does a disservice
to other people
most of the things you want to do
are not actually going to be physically
harmful to you
most of the things that you are afraid
to do
you're afraid of failing not even of the
failure you're afraid of failing in
front of people you're afraid of who
sees you when you're failing you're
afraid of if i fall down on the hill
who who's going to watch me remember
when i first learning to snowboard
if i was the only one on the hill and i
fell down no big deal when i fell down
and be looking oh who saw me fall down
again and again and again and again and
again be worried i'd be self-conscious
about who would see me fall right you're
not afraid of failing you're afraid of
who sees you when you fall and that's a
big deal because as long as you live
your life
in fear of what other people think of
you
you're never going to accomplish the
thing that you want to accomplish if you
are governed in your life by other
people's expectations of you you stay
small forever you're trying to please
everybody around you and live their
version of your life never get into that
you live your own version
and so you have to lean into
that fear
the goal isn't to offend the people
around you the goal is to say hey look i
told you so or i hate you or anything
like that it's not it has nothing to do
with them the goal is about living your
life
and so it's leaning into the things that
you're afraid of
right now i'm working on a big project
that is secret for the moment but stay
tuned it's coming
and and i'm afraid of it i'm afraid of
it i'm afraid
it's not going to work out i'm afraid
we're going to disappoint people i'm
afraid we're going to promise people
things and then not be able to deliver
and so i'm working really hard not to
have that become a reality but i'm i'm
really it's a big stretch from where i'm
at right now and i'm afraid that
it's not going to work i'm going to
disappoint people
and because that is the fear
i have to do it it's not a good enough
reason it means that you're on the right
track the thing that i'm afraid of means
i have to go off and do it to show
myself that evan carmichael does the
things that he's afraid of that's the
identity you want to build is that you
attack the things that you're afraid of
the path through the fear is through
not stopping
if you stop you'll always be afraid of
that thing
if you're bumping up against the fear
and then you say oh i can't do it i'm
afraid that fear will always own you
where every time you go through the fear
you get a little bit stronger you're
capable of doing more things you're
capable of taking on bigger projects and
bigger fears and inspiring the people
behind you right every time you take
that step of growth if you go to step
500 on the staircase of growth you can
help people get to step 4.99 but if
you're stuck at step two you can only
help people get to step one
so if you want to serve you want to give
you want to contribute you want to reach
your potential you want to be the
michael jordan genius that you've got
and share that with the world you have
to step into your fears and that becomes
an inspiration for other people as well
so how do you do it what's up what are
some practical steps for you to actually
execute this
step number one is recognize the fear
most of the time when you're afraid of
something we don't actually call it fear
we call it something something smarter
we call it a reason right which is
really just an excuse which is really
just fear but we call it a reason
i can't do that now
because i don't have enough time oh i
didn't go to school for that oh i don't
have the resources i don't i don't have
the experience uh i'm gonna start that
next week or this a great january first
goal and you convince yourself of all
the reasons why you can't do it
or
uh i'm a perfectionist and i can't i
can't start a youtube channel until i
have
until i have the right gear and the
right camera on the right what guys i'm
using a a an iphone and a headset i'm
making videos you can make video you
already have all the gear that you need
we come up with all these stories these
reasons and you believe the reason
because they're smart reasons
they're smart you wouldn't believe a
stupid reason it's a smart reason that's
what you're believing
but really just fear so step number one
is to actually catch the fear
to stop believing your excuses
catch the fear right and that's really
really really hard you probably won't
even catch it most of the time but
catching it in the moment as much as
possible is step number one step number
two is then doing the thing so when you
catch the fear
you have to then immediately go do the
thing
what is that thing maybe that thing is
making a phone call maybe that thing is
making a video maybe that thing is
writing that message maybe that thing is
booking the apartment booking the flight
like what is that thing for you to to
train yourself that you're not going to
delay
you caught the fear you're going to do
that thing immediately one of my
favorite things to do when i'm working
with people is as soon as they come up
with some goal some idea it's like okay
great what are we going to do right now
i was on an ig live yesterday on my
channel on instagram
where the guy was from south africa
and he wanted to start doing coaching
sessions on instagram
he says okay great let's let's start
you know what time is it there now nine
o'clock perfect okay so let's book your
your first coaching sessions and
i pulled people from the chat like who
would love to have a coaching session
with him
and we pulled the first two people to
say okay you're on tomorrow and you're
on the next day tomorrow morning you're
with him the next day you're with him
and i want an update it was uh what
i want an update on movement makers
right so he's part of my movie makers
program and we're going to meet on the
thursday so i want an update by thursday
i want to know how the first two went
and we booked it for him live
i love doing that kind of always like
immediate action go because you're
afraid like oh my god my heart's beating
boom boom boom boom
right
immediate action so one is catching the
fear
two is taking immediate action towards
it like right away you gotta we gotta do
something we gotta have the courage to
step into that fear
and then three is
boom boom boom test and that's when your
heart is beating boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom that helps feed
into step number one of catching the
fear
if you're in your head talking yourself
down from that big idea that you've got
that you can't do it and you're not
smart enough and you're not good enough
and all that stuff but you at the same
time feel your heart going like this
boom boom boom hey dogs hey tristana
where's timo
timo
oh oh okay he's looking he's looking for
nina she went shopping
he's not paying attention to me oh there
he is he's been here the whole time you
love it
you feel your heart going boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom
it means you're afraid
and even though your head's telling you
that you can't do it and finding logical
reasons really you're just afraid so use
the boom boom boom test i call it the
boom boom boom test when you can feel it
think about the idea that you've got
does it make your heart go boom boom
boom yes perfect go that feeds into
number one you're just afraid and that
feeds into number two which is take
immediate action
your your life is on the other side of
your fears
you have to decide
when do you stop
living in the fear and finally step into
the life that you want for yourself to
have the impact that you know you can
have to create the life that you want
for yourself for your family that they
deserve
everything you want everything
everything everything everything is in
the other side of your fears and it's
time
today to attack them
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
this isn't a magic act these are basic
skills
and basic skills are duplicatable
and the reason most salespeople have
such trouble is because for years we
have been trying sales professionals and
the gurus have been teaching
uh manipulation tactics
dodge the question
don't answer control the customer
uh the the whole newer linguistics book
these are gimmicks we have never hired
one person that had a neuro-linguistic
background that worked for us
successfully
so you guys are in the lnlp stuff i'm
just telling you we've hired
hundreds and hundreds of sales people
i've been with tens of thousands of
sales people i have never seen one
person that got into this neuro bull
that was a successful salesperson over
long periods of time and did not bring
drama to our organization
i don't want drama dude i want
production
so
so when when he sits a certain way i
don't start thinking about man um
imagine being in a sales sales
presentation i'm like i got to be like
him and then now i got to be like her
and now i got to be like him guess who
you can't be when you're doing that
you
you man what a dis
i want to be me
the power resonates for me my truth my
authenticity and my transparency
okay so
if you can't do that you can't build you
can't build a business and you certainly
can't duplicate it i never ask him to be
me i'm like hey bro when somebody says
the payments are too high what do you do
what do you say
well i'm with you
everybody try that
no no i didn't say it like that i said
i'm with you
see and i'm with you
hey man hey the price is too high i knew
that before you did
everybody try that
okay see i i'm he he gets to be him
but the words will work because all i'm
doing is basically agreeing with the
customer this isn't a trick here
okay uh this course is uh i'm doing a
dinner tonight for twenty five thousand
dollars at my house okay i think we got
two slots left
the entire 25 000
goes to the grant cardone foundation any
of you want to put 25 grand in please
see one of my people come have dinner at
my house we'll spend a couple hours over
there the money's going to go to help
kids some of you in a room immediately
say
oh my god 25 grand that's a lot of money
man i know that
you don't think i know 25 000 a lot of
money i'm the one that decided what the
freaking entry would be
i said what would be too much 25 grand
25 grand would be a lot of damn money
somebody gonna be like damn that's a lot
of money okay and the people that it's a
lot of money that think small that go
small and don't want to help won't come
to my house and have dinner
and the people they're like dude i'd go
spend two hours with that cat man for 25
grand get pictures with him at his new
home
with his family
with with eight or ten other people and
the money's going to charity and i get
to write it off i get to bang the irs
who hates the irs
well this is this is a chance to give
them a good
okay so you see what i'm doing i'm
handling all the objections right now i
understand 25 grand a lot of money man i
know what you got to do to earn 25 grand
you got to do crazy stuff to earn 25
grand and if you keep thinking that
earning 25 grand is always going to be a
problem for you hopefully for everybody
in the room one day you're going to be
able to earn 25 000 every hour
all commitments require investments in
time and money all commitments
you cannot make a commitment without
time and money being invested
time and money has to be invested you
have to invest time and money if it's
not on your schedule you're not
committed if you don't have money back
by that time on your calendar if it's
not costing you money or you don't have
money deposited right there you are not
committed
where you have your money is where your
personal spiritual emotional physical
commitments go wherever your money is is
who you are most committed to
wells fargo bank of america citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
wells fargo than you have invested in
your own advertising in the market
because you guys are committed to the
lie
the big marketing scam of the universe
save your money
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not borrow
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
and one day you too
will be able to stay at a holiday inn
for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there and
eat all you want for as long as you want
by the way
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the
belt that you bought and put on your
credit card
that you can't write off by them
so this is what americans are doing
people all around the world spend 40
hours a week running around hustling
yeah they get 100 what do they do now
they run over here to the bank drop off
the 100 bucks then they run back out do
another 40 weeks pick up a thousand
dollars man i had a great week didn't i
bang and then they run over here and
drop it off at the bank these are the
good americans
the bad americans go pick up a thousand
bucks go to the club and blow it
the good americans run
run around collecting a thousand dollars
five thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars hustlers hustlers man hard
workers they they get sophisticated ugh
i'm gonna put a little money in the bank
over here over here at wells fargo i'm
going to have a little over here
citibank i'm going to spread this
around
i want to be a slave to many
not a slave to a few
i'm going to give a little the bank of
america i'm going to give a little bit
citibank i'm going to give a little bit
to the wells fargo i'm going to give a
little bit to fidelity and merrill lynch
i'm going to give a little bit to my ira
and my 401 k i'm going to bust my ass
i'm going to spend 40 years killing
myself to make sure all these
institutions
have my money
where they pay me nothing
for the sake of security
[Music]
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me up
hey mr cardone
we got another dummy
[Music]
guy spent goddamn he must have spent 160
hours
put together a little bank extremely
disciplined dumbass
and and he
saved hundred thousand dollars with us
and we'd like to know mr cardone if you
would like to borrow that money
his money
yeah i sure would because we know mr
cardone that you will put that money to
work
okay
this guy that gave it to us all he wants
to do is work
i'm like yeah send me that money bro
send me that money okay and they by the
way they're not done calling me they're
gonna call nine other people
they're gonna take his 100 grand and
they're gonna say they're gonna
they're gonna lend it out 900
000
of it and this is the banking system
and that is debt by the way
that u.s dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them
to keep for you
you have to prepare for inflation
hitting you
and
look i just want to give you a heads up
on this thing it's happening right now i
believe we're already in a recession not
to be a doomsday guy because i think
that there's ways for you to take
advantage of this but i just passed one
two three four five six shops and
nobody's in them
so the american consumer has like 18
trillion dollars between cash accounts
and money markets you can't get negative
right now when you see the bad news this
is an opportunity for you and your
family to actually expand
not contract
so you're going to see bad news in the
headlines everywhere once the the
politicians start allowing
uh the mass media to actually distribute
the bad news and we're not talking about
you crane and cobid we're not talking
about abortion uh
uh rulings because all that is just
distraction for the bigger problem which
is the economy
the economy is problematic okay you got
the fed pushing interest rates
a half a point yesterday
uh there was a rebound in the stock
market this morning i wake up the stock
market rolls over by a thousand points
okay there's going to be blood in the
market so i'm going to do a training on
this i'm going to give you a few tips
right now but first thing is you got to
wake up you got to wake up to what's
happening you got to know that hey
what do i do now what do i do if this
happens one do not buy into the bad news
okay two you got to expand into the
opportunity and it's very very difficult
to do
uh you've heard of wealthy people doing
this before how they take advantage of
situations okay i'm gonna show you how
to do that whether you have cash or no
you don't have cash whether you have
credit or don't have credit
because during times of contraction what
happens is
for instance there's 32 million small
businesses in america
many of you are going out trying to
start a new business where what you
ought to do is just kind of slide
sideways and go buy one the neighbor
next door to you
i mean from laundry maps to plumbers to
internet businesses to coaching
businesses you name it chiropractors
dentists like in every sector that
you're involved in right now in your
business or your interests or your
passion i'll promise you
there are
thousands
thousands not one or two but thousands
of small businesses like yours
that are similar to your passion that
would feed your passion that already
have branding already have marketing
built in already have a name already
have a location already have revenue
already have credit lines that you can
literally just slide into
okay but you're not gonna do that you're
not gonna do that if all you're doing is
buying into bad news
so number one you can't buy into the bad
news because
remember all bad news sooner or later
is beat out by the need to survive and
the economy to go on the economy will
always go on
okay not just here in america but around
the world always always always we always
get on the other side of bad news so the
first thing you do is you got to keep
your head out of the garbage dump
you got to stay positive and trust me
when it goes negative
it is not easy to stay positive
people always like oh yeah i can stay
positive on my own probably not because
you're not going to be on your own
you're going to be surrounded by bad
news everywhere so number two you got to
think about how do you expand despite
the fact that you don't have money and
you don't have credit or you do have
money and you do have credit but you
don't want to use either one because
you're terrified and you will be
the third thing you have to figure out
to do okay is exactly what sectors will
survive
long term
what sectors are going to win through
contractions because what happens in a
contraction
what happens is weak businesses get
squeezed out weak names get squeezed out
okay a weak operators get squeezed out
and the strong come in and take over
that either the technology takes over
and disrupts a space or a person
typically a person or an operator comes
in and then scales that business
the theme that runs in my life is just
disappointment throughout the whole
thing particularly the first from fifth
to from 10 years old to 25
and then 25 to
50
you know
yeah i was doing better because i i had
a drug problem at 16. oh you did yeah
was that the disappointment or was it
like no no no the drugs were just the
drugs were a byproduct you know it was
the disappointment was
you know
the school thing
school was disappointing no uncles no
dad
no i didn't know direction just boredom
that's why what you do with these
the races at least keep somebody
occupied for some moment of time that
gives them a goal big enough and a
challenge sure i didn't have any
challenges you didn't have anybody like
setting some goals up in front of us no
no no when my dad died i kept waiting
for one of the uncles to step up and
they didn't got him and that pissed me
off because i'm like dude somebody's got
to step up and give me a little guidance
here but you but you had older um
brothers my older brother died when i
was 20. right so 10 years after my dad
died so there was no men
just a bunch of women and mom mom wasn't
like setting big goals for you no no my
mom my mom my mom grew up in bread lunch
so
you know i'd go to my mom i remember i
did a deal when i was 30. i bought my
first piece of real estate
and
mom i bought this piece of real estate
it was three million dollars a 1.9
million dollars and she's like wow
that's great but you know i just i love
you just the way you are
right and i hung up the phone she said
that to me a thousand times
and i humped the phone said yeah but i
don't love me the way i am
and then the my counselor buddy dale
says you need to love yourself the way
you are i said ain't never gonna happen
dude
all right i said that's the big lot
i don't want to love me in the way i
want to become the guy i should be
i just had a coaching call with some
friends of mine they come in every month
and and they're working on the business
they're going to bust a million dollars
this month when i met them they were
literally the company was not making
money they're going to make a million
dollars they asked me a question today
that i want to talk about they're like
dude how are you
everybody we talk to talks about being
nice to their people taking care of
their people doing this for their people
why is it the the the answer you have is
different i said what do you mean
well it seems like you're hard on people
i said no man i'm not being hard on
people
i'm just trying to take care of my
environment
i'm not trying i don't practice being a
a dik
i'm trying
to take care of my environment my
decisions are about my environment right
so little grant
it little grants this this little phone
right here this is little grant he got
issues he needs to clean up his issues
grant's got to get hard on grant
okay you you guys out there y'all y'all
so soft on your people it's cause you're
soft on yourself
right that's why you end up with no
money
you end up with people betraying you you
end up with people taking advantage of
you even your kids don't appreciate you
do you got to be hard on yourself i'm
hard on everybody around me but mostly
i'm hard on me i'm making 2.4 million
dollars a year
if i could figure out how to get another
200 that's called value add v8 value ad
if i could figure out how to raise the
rents 200 bucks
531 units
see that's why the number of units is so
in part
531
[Music]
106 000
times what
is what one point
[Music]
see that creates another one million two
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars of income a year
i'm already making 2.4 million dollars a
year
that traffic jam
okay i got more cash flow
i just got i don't have to go work i
don't have to beat stuff up
i don't have to go uber you guys are
i'm going to go uber to what what you go
uber to
you end up with seven dollars
same energy folks same energy
spend the energy going someplace getting
a vehicle that can actually get you to
freedom
i don't want money this money i've had
this money here the whole time okay
it ain't gonna do anything
how many got money in the bank right now
it's useless
[Music]
money is useless until it is put to use
people earn money
and then they spend it
and you're just doing this thing
comes in it goes out
you have to have multiple exits on the
way out
how do i get out of this deal
i know people that have bought real
estate that they're like in cash flows
but they're like i cannot i can never
get rid of this piece of property it's
always going to be a problem for me hang
me around my neck
but it pays me a little bit of money
okay now if it's only one unit if it's
only one unit folks and it makes you 500
a month it's still only 500 a month
everybody agree that's why you don't
want to go small you got to figure out
how to do it big if you do it big if you
do it right if you have the right
location the barriers to entry if you
have the cash flow that you need if you
get good debt on it i promise you you
will not lose money in this space
warren buffett said don't lose money
number two what
number three
exactly so when when i read that i'm
like don't lose money don't lose money
don't lose money
what do i invest in
oh invest in something that doesn't lose
money don't speculate don't buy stocks
like i don't want to trade a piece of
paper for a piece of paper it's a piece
of paper when you go buy twenty dollars
with a google stock what do you get
you get a piece of paper bag
it's all made up
kids steal it anyway
okay i want something i can see would
you agree
okay i would rather have that that money
i'd rather take this money and say okay
here's a hundred dollars here's a
hundred dollars i'm gonna take the
hundred dollars and i'm gonna buy a flip
charger
this flip chart is more valuable
than that hundred dollars
if i use it
everybody agree okay so i want you to
write this down quit saving money
the banks have brainwashed you
save your money save your money save
your money save your money the the wall
street also did this stay liquid stay
liquid stay liquid you want liquidity no
you do not want liquidity you want to be
ill-liquid and you do not want to save
money people should be studying the most
successful companies in the world not
not individuals
don't worry about dave or gary or tony
or grant
what are successful people doing
you know i
one of the biggest mistakes i've made in
my life was tracking
people that were doing better than me
so what
like like like i made so many dumb ass
decisions because
uh dave did it
or the millionaire next door that that
book
i don't want to be the millionaire next
door i want to know what jeff bezos is
doing i want to know what the boys at
google are doing okay why why does a guy
like mark zuckerberg go from college
dorm room to one of the richest people
on the planet
that's who we should be studying
and and don't listen to everybody else
because those people have financial
freedom to the point to where they they
can do anything they want
like you cannot mess up some of these
people's situation
they couldn't screw it up if they wanted
to
so uh the 10x rule is is a it says hey
look you want to scale to a point
to where you have the life you deserve
it's not about the money you want or the
money you need
scale your business so you can walk away
from it and money never stops taking
care of you and your family you don't
need to study 27 different warrants
you study one more and you're probably
going to be good
most of us because of instagram and
facebook and youtube we're listening to
so many different people
that that people do nothing
this this is the new crisis of our era
people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting
so if you listen to dave dave says buy a
house then you listen to grant grant
says that's stupid you're not going to
do anything
and if you're never going to buy any
real estate hey go ahead and buy one
house yeah you're going to regret it
later and you're going to be like i wish
i had done what cardone said but but you
got to do something and what you don't
want to do is listen
to god and the devil
because then you get stuck in purgatory
and you don't have any fun at all
you need to dream big i mean you cannot
dream big enough i'm telling you you
can't dream big enough
you can do more than you're doing
but you can't do more than you're doing
if you hang around with little thinkers
that could be your family members could
be your friends could be people you're
going to school with and hanging out
with look there's a time and a place to
hang out with those people
can't pick your family i mean they say
you can't i wonder sometimes we don't
actually do the picking
and just show up there
without saying that for another
conversation
but i do know once
once you get with your family the family
that you picked or they picked or
however that might work the selection
process
wherever you went to school or go to
school or where you grew up or how you
grew up or religion you grew up in or
whether you're white or black or brown
male or female the question is always
going to be
what can you do
to do more with your life
to find your mission to find your
purpose
to find what you're great at to get
great at the things maybe that you're
not great at that you don't even like
doing think big
telling you can do more and you will do
more than
than you ever imagined if you're ever
successful in your life if you ever hit
it
and you can
you will look back
10 15 20 years from now and say god what
was i thinking
what was i thinking i promise you
you know it's like 80 pounds of weight
looks like a lot
when you're 5 or 6 years old
later it's pretty easy to pick that up
no matter what your frame is as long as
you do the work as long as you do the
work and show up in the gym one day
you'll be able to pick that barbell up
just like in life okay the things that
you think are impossible today the
things that you hate today the things
that you aren't good at the things that
you think are a waste of time the things
that make you angry
are all opportunities for you how many
rooms are broke right now you're broke
you're like just dead broke
like like if i went and banged on your
credit card it would scream and call the
police
now uh alert 9-1-1 call them out right
now this cannot be used again
that's fine dude that's fine you still
need to have your dreams
you need to start dreaming now how old
are you dude
22 years old you got any money at all
but he's got a little he's got a little
diamond in his ear right here he ain't
got any money but he's like
i'm shining
i'm shining
huh i'm trying to come here come here
man yeah come here man come here i'm
sorry ah
i got a little cubic
[Applause]
come on up here man 22 years old man 22
years old you know what i was doing
every day 22 years old how what do you
weigh man how much you weigh oh you got
one in both ears look at this
get a close-up can you get a close-up
look at that man
oh he's so cool he's so cool look he
looks good too man looks good okay look
how much money do you have to your name
probably like a thousand thousand bucks
what
i feel like a million bucks though yeah
yeah
either way bro you're broke
you agree with that oh yeah bro you guys
need to admit you need to own you need
to know when you're broke the man's got
a thousand dollars
right he goes to jail today
he's broke
so so like but but that does not that
does not mean you can't dream
so right now what he's going to do is he
his dreams are going to be like okay man
like i just want to i just want to get a
a two grand
or i just want to get some of these
or i want to get a watch but that's not
the dream folks
you know when you were a kid when you're
a kid 12 years old what do you want you
want a car i can't wait till i get the
car you don't think about i'm going to
own a car dealership
you think i want a car you don't think
hey man i'm gonna make a new car that
flies
right see that's why he ended up with
these little cubics
because his dreams aren't big enough get
off the stage
okay but he's in the right place
he's in the right place everybody agree
from 15 to 25 i was using drugs every
day
so when i tell you
hey you can do anything
i was
a habitual
daily drug user
overdosed three times
was brought back by people just
wandering into a room saying oh this
guy's in trouble
okay i was i don't know if i was trying
to kill myself at the time or i was just
didn't know what i was doing or stupid
or whatever like
i was a walking time bomb
and i was not to be trusted by my family
by my friends
there was no one in my life between 15
and 25 that i could have a positive
influence on
i was a liability
to everyone in my life including my
family
and my friends and people i went to
school with and the places i worked at i
lost seven jobs in a row i was
unemployable
25 i went to a treatment center and said
i got to turn this around
i got to turn this around i cannot keep
using drugs they're bad for me i make
poor decisions when i'm using them
i i i go out with the wrong people hang
with the wrong people end up in the
wrong fights i literally got like when
you're using drugs you're going to pick
fights you can't win not in a lifetime
you're going to get in the wrong cars
make the wrong decisions the wrong
purchases
and you're going to miss a lot of great
opportunities
so first thing is
you can't do great things
if you're incapable of making great
decisions
and when you're
under the influence
and i don't want to preach to you i'm
just telling you what what advice i'd
give myself if i was on the comeback and
i was
15 years old and being influenced by
everybody smoking the kush
it's cool now
it's probably going to be legal
everywhere
going out drinking on the weekends
forgetting everything that you
did and just making poor decisions so i
tell you hey you got you got to figure
out how how is that going to somehow
advance your life you're going to have
to make some hard choices if i'm a young
guy coming up young gal coming up how
can i pick great relationships when
everybody's under the influence
and again i don't mean to sound like a
like a
a preacher or anything because i'm
definitely not that we're going to have
a great time this weekend
i'm here for a week we're going to have
a lot of fun but i couldn't do that if i
was still under the influence every day
so i have 12 employees i'm sure at one
point you had you know four or five
employees how did you go from four or
five to whatever you have
i had i had two employees
from the age of
29
no no from the age of 30 to
38 years old i had two employees
for eight years
i did everything i was the secretary
phone answer
uh
i did payroll stole for myself
did my taxes i did my own taxes i
wouldn't pay anybody anything
okay from
uh 30 to 38 38 to 45 i added like two or
three people
[Music]
i was i was officing
out of the guest house
at my my my place that i lived at in in
los angeles it's a big guest house
it was a dude it was an awesome hour
lionel richie lived in that house
you know
[Music]
it was a cool house right
but it was small thinking man i was
still thinking little
[Music]
and if you're going to stay small you're
going to get crushed so i'll push you
over the edge 2009 2008 and 2009.
so what eventually made you say you know
what i'm just going to make it
what happened was a guy told me years
before that that bigger's not better and
i believed it
because he busted out
he busted out when he went big and he
says grant bigger's not better man stay
small
and i and i believe that dude and i
carried it on a long time it's bad
advice knowledge is power
bad knowledge is too
so what i did was i stayed small until i
was 45 years old
five employees i was one of them
so four
and um
when 2008 came i'm like this was stupid
dude like i got a scale
and and that was what 12 uh how many
years ago was that nine years
seven or eight years ago there was no
jet
there was no big office
it just shows you man when you change
your mind when you change your mind and
start like hey i'm gonna scale this
thing out i'm gonna go global i'm gonna
have people know me i'm gonna get
attention i'm gonna get my products out
i'm going to lower my prices i'm going
to bring this thing to market i'm going
to get big bring in good people we have
how many employees we have now charity
72 at the office we got our partners
here tonight we got an another 150 in uh
in in the real estate game
we're gonna expand that we'll probably
pick up another 12 or 15 this month
because the two more deals we're
bringing on
and next year i'm talking about going
global so all everything that happened
everything has happened really good to
us it's happened because of the
expansion
you failed the business no problem
you restart another business
so the way to play this is let's go
ahead and give your business the best
shot
you need training you're going to need
sales you're going to need phone skills
you're going to need follow-up otherwise
it's going to fail okay now watch we put
it on a credit card
if we put it on a credit card and you
fail
the bankruptcy court picks up the visa
mastercard the american express
the training contract you
you you did with us lives on for your
next company
you guys understand that
100 of those people
will continue on in some other business
a few of them will commit suicide
okay i'm done
but the rest of them are going to be
like i got to go do something and they
are going to restructure and start
another company donald trump has
restructured casinos man this is not a
new thing like the big boys restructure
okay
fail boom we restructure we'll create
something new i still got a business
okay you got to get this guy to see this
might fail but you won't because you
won't quit and you're going to be over
here pay the price today okay learn to
discipline yourself
if you got to go to the gym every day if
you hate going to the gym go to the gym
i don't like going to the gym but i'm
like i don't like my body hurting either
sooner or later if you don't go to the
gym and work your body your body will it
will scream at you and it will hurt
lower back pains arms shoulders knees
you name it it's always gonna hurt and
as long as it's hurting how can you be
fully available for the people around
you if your body's certain two you gotta
eat good foods okay gotta make decisions
i ain't gonna eat junk
i'm not gonna eat the junk why why
because i'm saying no to junk
and if you can start saying no to stuff
you can start saying yes to the good
things like my little girl right there
sabrina say hi sabrina
so pay the price today learn how to be
great at jobs you hate
that's paying the price get up early
go to bed early okay beat the sun up
every morning it'll give you so much
confidence i'm paying the price when i
do that when i get up before the sun
gets up i'm paying the price when i go
to bed at nine o'clock and i'm not
watching tv and movies and just being
entertained an effect of whatever's
coming my way i'm paying the price
when i don't waste the weekends the
weekends make you weak listen to me
weekends are for a week people
anything after 10 o'clock at night it's
for weak people
okay saturday and sunday staying up all
night weak people people are made weak
on the weekends
pay the price okay give up the weekends
for the next
five years
and watch what happens
five years man that's a lot of weekends
that's what is that 250 weekends is that
right yeah 250 weekends that means i'm
ahead of the people around me
i'm paying the price today
in hopes that i could pay any price in
the future and i just thought we'd take
a shot at one of these obnoxious
[Music]
car videos because i know you guys love
automobiles probably more than i love
them as the private jet flies over us
this is a completely obnoxious just i'm
just gonna be completely transparent for
all the haters and the naysayers and the
[ __ ]
all of you out there that hate on people
that are successful i thought i'd give
you something to hate on today because
content is king right
[Music]
okay today we have my driver car my
driver card is what i roll in this is
the 2021 cullinan rolls royce cullinan
454 thousand dollars of nothing but
super swag obnoxious thank you bernie
marino
the next senator of ohio by the way for
this complete obnoxious beast of an
automobile okay this is not dog friendly
by the way you put a dog back here boom
that bad boy gonna be dead okay now to
my tuesday car to my tuesday car spider
458
458 what is it
488 i ain't got my numbers right but i
got my money right okay 488 low rider
tuesday get me ready for hump day okay
this thing is so fast it is freaking
unbelievable brings me to my wednesday
car you know what they say about
wednesdays this hump day okay this is
man this thing is nothing but just
freaking stupid luxury
stupid bentley luxury
368 000 of nothing but obnoxious
to bring me to my washer car okay 180
000 mercedes v8 beautiful four-door
sedan when those bad boys are getting
washed i take a day off and drive in the
little bends
just to keep me grateful about the build
much
crazy stuff i got up there okay
that brings me to my friday car right do
i have a friday car yeah this is my
thursday car this is my friday rider
this is when i go dj khaled
we the best
this is a phantom folks this is 650 000
and nothing but beast
obnoxious
freaking crazy black on black badge
but let me show you what i use on the
weekends
this
is the vehicle
that does it all for me
okay what's up man
my taco truck saturday sundays is my
taco truck this is how i paid for all
the obnoxious
selling on the weekends weekends are for
the week
taco trucks for the terrific go get you
a damn taco truck so you can buy all
this obnoxious
bentley bling
italiano fratello
familia
calinan cuisine
grant cardone is the king and i'm
obnoxiously
like my video
my wealth ultimately is not the money i
have it's the knowledge i have
and the belief i have in myself the same
thing for you
but i want to take you on this trip
because look number one you got to
visualize it you got to be able to see
it in your mind like possibility second
thing is you got to see it
you know in the physical universe you
can explain to me what a bougainvillea
is you can explain to me what a beach is
you can explain to me what
uh the gym looks like on the second
floor in cabo san lucas at this
beautiful hotel we're at but
until i visually visually physically put
an image to the ocean to the whales to
the sunshine to the mountains until i
visually see it it doesn't become real
third thing you want to do number one
see it in your mind
i was uh i was doing a call today with
percy miller uh master p
and he's like first thing you got to do
is see it in your mind he grew up in
extreme poverty in the projects and he
says grant first thing i had to do was i
had to see it
in my mind that i could get out second
thing i had to do was see a picture of
it in the physical universe
that's how valuable the internet is
today is that you get to see things that
maybe are way outside your price range
you can see the lambo the rolls the big
house the trip
you can see the possibility of elon
going to mars you know and and all of a
sudden all those things expand
possibilities so number one you got to
see it in your mind too you got to see
it in the physical universe and this
also includes other people examples of
other people that are doing great things
i'm not just talking about physical
manifestation i'm not talking about
stuff i'm not talking about watches and
bracelets and rings and houses and cars
i'm talking about how can you actually
manifest something in the real world
that you have in your mind how do you
turn an idea
into reality
and uh these things that i'm sharing
with you will make i'll make it a
possibility uh when you dig deep on them
though it's like okay well how do i get
closer to people that are doing those
things because the third thing is you
got to get closer to the thing you want
if you want a gulf stream
or if you want to solve the water
problem on planet earth you're going to
have to get closer physically closer
step on not just see with your eyes in a
magazine or on the internet you need to
put your feet in the sand put your feet
on the jet
now that might mean that you got to go
fuel jets for a while you got to go work
at an aviation company
an airport and actually fuel them clean
them wash them maybe you got to be a
flight attendant on them put your feet
next to them maybe you have to become a
pilot you're going to have to pay the
price though there's no free lunch here
for anybody including my children
there's no free lunch
there's no way to know what this room
feels like the expansiveness of this
room by looking at on the internet the
moment you can get in it it'll be become
even more real to you the fourth thing
is you got to put your feet in this deal
you got to put your feet in this deal
there's a there's a horse down there i
can you can visualize a horse you can
see the horse
you you got to touch the horse and the
fourth thing i'm sorry you got to touch
the hearts and the fourth thing is you
guys got to collaborate with other
people man you got to get in the room
with other people whether you're serving
water
if they don't invite you to sit down
then offer them money to sit down with
them if that doesn't work
um offer to serve them to sit down okay
there's a story in my life could be
wrapped up in these four things right
here number one see it in my mind number
two see it in the physical universe like
see it in in some not physical but in
metaverse
on the internet in a magazine a picture
of it third get closer to it put your
feet on it
on the plane on the horse on the beach
in the hotel if i got to go work there
to do it and the fourth thing is
you got to network with people that have
stuff
okay
again uh i spent some time this week
with uh dame dash she's like look you
got to get close to the action you got
to get with the people that are making
the moves you cannot make the moves from
your own neighborhood uh percy miller
told me you cannot make the moves from
the projects you got to move from the
projects not make the moves in the
project quit working street corners
quit selling just a product and start
hanging out with people that have scaled
their think their ideas
into a reality your bank money right now
is earning point zero zero two five
percent
my real estate's earning 20
if you have no place to go you see when
i was 26 years old i was broke 27 i was
broke 28 i was broke 29 i was broke 30 i
was broke you know why because i take
the five grand and i push it off to the
side and i was broke again hustling took
get another five grand why because i
knew where i was going i was going here
i'm like i'm gonna be a millionaire dude
ain't nobody gonna take this deal from
me and i am not gonna wait till i'm 90
years old to get the million bucks
right by the time i'm 33 years old i had
1 million 125
127 bucks in a damn account 1 million
125 127 33 years old and i started with
no money at 25. how
i got the 5 000. i don't need to go buy
something yet i got to add that every
year now i need to learn how to get that
money to grow
20 a year
it'll take me 20 years
to get it done how did i get it done in
eight years
[Music]
i must have either added money
or earn more than 20
and it was a combination of both how do
you do that
you don't do it at your job
you can't go you can't be a waitress
making you know 40 000 bucks a year and
all of a sudden make 20 more it's your
job you can't like it just that you
can't just all of a sudden say i'm 20
better give me 20 more money and even if
you could you'll do it one time not
every year
francisco it cannot be such a good
cameraman that he's like hey dude look
give me a 20 raise this year all right
can he do it again next year sooner or
later i'm gonna be like
tapping out dawg okay your photos aren't
that good
i mean they were good
but now they're getting expensive i'm 63
years old you know i'll be 64 in march
and
you know i feel like i'm like 14 years
old man i'm like let's roll like let's
let's go i'm ready to run through walls
and
you know fly and learn new stuff i'm
studying uh kryptos right now in the
metaverse and like what happens and when
do i make a play and do i make a play
and what is all this so you one number
one you have to stay curious
[Music]
number one curious you have to be
curious when clubhouse came around
clubhouse is an audio app if you don't
know what that is
a couple years ago most of people in my
office including jared was like man
hey nothing there's nothing there
you know i'm like oh there's people
there though
there's people there and what i
discovered because i was curious about
clubhouse is not because i was curious
about social media i was curious about
people
to me i get energy from people
and so um
i've been in rooms where uh alan have
y'all met alan yet
so alan allen saw me go in a room one
night and he text me he's like what the
hell you doing in this room man
and i said what's up he's like get out
of this room
and i said what you worried about he's
like you're the only white person in the
room and the title is white entitlement
and he sends me a little sweaty emoji
i said bro where how am i going to learn
about white entitlement with white
people
like you got to be curious folks just
because it has nothing to do with you
doesn't mean your market's not there and
for me to be able to market to a market
means i need to understand how that
market thinks
so one of the great benefits of me being
curious particularly about two-way
communication on on social media the
feedback
i'm not looking for likes and comments
i'm looking for something some
electricity in the moment what you're
talking about the drive potential
potential an idea like all my ideas come
from i don't fabricate ideas
everything you see me do happened it was
happening already in the universe
i don't i don't create anything i just
grab something that's already there
and i grab it out of something i hear
so the supreme court today announced
they kicked out the mandate uh for the
vaccine i'm like hey man
[Applause]
okay good you like it or don't like it
y'all need to get on one side of that
story and start talking to people about
it so you gain that audience
you need to you need oh i don't want to
be political
say that's stupid man
you know there's nothing that raises
more money than politics
nothing there's nothing
and most of it's just a scam
and everybody knows that they're like
i'm throwing in they ain't throwing in
for their side they're throwing in to
keep the other side that they're worried
about the point of the story is there's
energy there
there's tremendous amounts of energy
that you want to you want to tap into if
you could walk the line and play both of
them that'd be super cool
very difficult to do that though
so when that came out today i'm like
good job man like i got to take a stand
on that now will i lose some people 100
percent
i don't care who i lose there's 8
billion people on this planet
i'm worried about who doesn't know me
so the way to protect your brand
the way to protect your brand is to
expand it
that's the only way to protect your
brand
i'm 19 years old and i run a consulting
firm and uh right now i just tell you
real estate stuff and i have only about
60 grand from what i've done saved up
yeah and do you think i need to still
wait until 100 grand to invest in real
estate
how long you had 60 grand uh for just
like 12 months now yeah dude like you
got to get the other 40 bro
it's an arbitrary number i just made up
the number it could be 110 it could be
dude it's just it's just so you know
first of all when you get to 100 call me
and i'm gonna probably tell you hey man
you need to wait till you got 350.
but at least then you're gonna be like
you know what i i learned how to make i
learned how to not just make 100 save
100 and put 100 away
people are investing too soon you guys
are investing three grand here two grand
over here a thousand bucks 500 you're
walking away from it it's never worth
any money it's dumb
and you never create the discipline what
you end up with is a bunch of losses a
bunch of little losses
rather than knowing i have the
confidence that i can make money set it
aside protect it
right protect it like a kid
right
it's not going to get in a wreck i don't
lose it
i would do that first
so was there an age i didn't invest my
my first investment was five thousand
dollars and i blew it
and i'm like i'm not doing that again my
next investment's going to be big
where i'm gonna watch it
because if it's big enough dude if your
life depends on it you'll get up in the
mornings and you'll watch it
so my next deal was 350 grand it took
three years to do it all i did was save
money save money save money i put 350
grand in the deal sold that deal for
four million dollars a four million
dollar profit put every last penny you
had i had i had one third of all my
money in that deal i had a million
dollars like a million one
put 350 in my first deal 30 days later
put 450 in a second deal 90 days later
put all the rest of my capital 100 of
all my money
plus 90 grand
in three real estate deals
those are the first three investments i
ever made
the first three or four investments i
made in my entire life
three of the four did the little one
didn't
the little one couldn't work
it's impossible to work it was too small
what's it gonna do
it's not gonna do anything
it's like going into a casino and you
bet 15
right you get blackjack
so what it's still 15
the first thing you're going to say is
dude i should have bet everything
but you didn't
shouldn't even be in there
look behind a jet was something i never
dreamed i'd do i never okay i only
started thinking about it four or five
years ago when i'm young and broke i'm
growing up in louisiana middle class
being told be grateful you gotta bite on
a bike be grateful you got clothes on
your back and you get three meals be
grateful for all that you got cause you
got it better than i do i never dreamed
of having my own damn checks
whatever you have to do to keep your
purpose burning hot you do it you borrow
money okay use money if it requires
money so be it if you're truly obsessed
it will be worth it because you will get
the results you know the secret to
sustaining the obsession is a
straightforward one focus your efforts
on everything that will fuel you for the
long run and ignore eliminate and block
out anything
that drains you or causes you doubt
money power fame success all all of them
follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow the problem with these things
is money power fame and success even
time off
they require attention they're like
jealous lovers they need constant
attention or they're gonna leave you how
you invest your time is more important
than how you invest your money being
obsessed with your sense of purpose
across every part of your life will
allow you to accomplish all the things
you desire i think most people are not
accomplishing what they want in one area
of life because they quit on all the
other ones if you quit on all the other
ones how are you going to get this one
to run
nothing inspires me more than
surrounding myself with people who have
achieved more than i have and then
meeting new people i need the obsessed
must surround themselves with people you
trust and respect who think big who've
done bigger than you and who can help
you get to where you want to go you
think you can run only so fast
time is no longer an excuse because the
obsessed
make time they don't make excuses five
grand is a doable deal how do i do it
it's four hundred and twelve dollars a
month
okay i gotta go steal the money i can
steal five thousand you could steal five
grand for me and i wouldn't even know
it's gonna be like
if you could add five thousand of that
and earn twenty percent it'd be worth a
million one twenty five if you can do
this at 10 it'll be worth 320. some of
you small thinkers out there be like
dude i'll take the 320. how do i get 10
and how do i get 20. you guys have
figured this out you're like
if the play is big enough dude i'll
figure that out everybody agree see what
i just i shifted your mind by giving you
a target
i don't go to target i get targets and i
keep targets and i refresh the target
and the target is i want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
i got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20
a year over 20 years
and that is when your boy gc
got rich
i didn't get rich speaking i didn't get
rich selling books
i got rich shopping real estate
30 years old shopping every weekend dude
every weekend all i did between 25 and
30 years old was make money make money
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside even when in the
first years when i was not watch this
even when i was not
25 years old five grand boom next year
five grand
boom next year five grand
boom guess what next year oh by the way
this money is sitting dead in the bank
it's not not only anything it's it's in
a it's in a holy account
holy means okay i'm gonna put a hole in
your face if you touch my money
nobody could get this money this is a
like sacred account okay you with me 28.
oh wow man i could add a little bit
maybe there's more money
what am i doing right here okay
one two three four boom i got 25 000
sitting in an account
it wasn't a million dollars and i'm five
years into the plan
but when i was ready to start investing
money i started doing my homework 30
years old
homework
shopping properties 31 homework shopping
properties 32. i'm not buying cars you
guys are buying cars flying on jet
charters showing off going on vacations
all i'm doing is stacking paper
guess what happens i have five years of
putting five grand away next thing you
know i had twenty five thousand dollars
to add to my twenty five thousand
dollars next year i'm making more money
i got twenty five thousand 000 you see
what i'm doing i'm stacking dough
and looking
for 20
i know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to one million
remember this and let's open up the
calls okay
your job is to find a vehicle that can
pay you 20 a year might be a business
might be the business you're in it might
be to buy advertising for the business
or brand you're in for me it was this
i'm gonna buy real estate
that over long periods of time
i will earn cash flow okay that's how
the real estate works
i put 25 000 in a deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
a year
[Music]
you said yeah but grant you said what'd
you say grant would you say
20 grand that's what you said yeah i
know what i said
this ain't eddie okay now how much do i
have i could reinvest that money back in
the deal the next year i have 27
[Music]
500.
i earned 10 on that
that's 27.50 or something like that
i reinvest that now i got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the the
rent on this property as i own it over
20 years
2038 will dispose of this thing the rent
is going up as i'm adding money the
rent's going up and maybe this goes from
10 a
year
by the time i sell i want to be at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
a year
so when you start taking money and start
compounding it like that
for long periods of time the trick is
long periods of time if you want another
awesome grant cardone video check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and i'll
see you there